on va scanner le QR code pour le numéro
19 pour découvrir notre mission armée de
votre smartphone immergez-vous au sein
des légendes de notre hexagone c'est le
concept de ce jeu d'enquête proposé par
France Miniature à Élancourt la fée
Morgan ancienne élève du magicien Merlin
a jeter un sortilège sur tout le pays et
pour semer le chaos et la réveillé les
créatures fantastiques de nos régions la
bête du Gévaudan la Tarasque ou encore
le fantôme de la dame bleue vous devrez
résoudre des problèmes pour retrouver la
quiétude du territoire il y a des
énigmes d'observation des énigmes des
défis mathématiques des défis graphiques
beaucoup de choses qui attendent les
familles les petits comme les grands
d'abord il faut additionner la hauteur
de la tour à la hauteur de la flèche
replongée dans le monde de l'imaginaire
à travers cette enquête
intergénérationnelle le smartphone
permet de visionner du contenu audio et
vidéo nécessaire à la résolution des
énigmes une autre manière de découvrir
le parc France Miniature et d'apprendre
en s'amusant ça devient un outil un peu
pédagogique on véhicule les histoires on
leur explique pas mal de choses aussi
sur les monuments et les enfants ça les
ça les anime un peu plus parce que des
fois ils peuvent être impatient parce
qu'on est on prend le temps que là il y
a un jeu derrière donc ça emmène une
autre dynamique le parcours en lui-même
il est juste magnifique et je trouve que
le fait d'avoir un petit jeu comme ça
pour pour les joueurs pour relever des
défis etc je trouve ça trop canon la
France des légendes sera proposée tout
au long de l'année 2023 Nicolas Flamel
l'a fait Mélusine et Jean lafouce vous
attendent durant les vacances de Pâques
pour vous aider dans votre quête